สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนครูนิกวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันนี้
วันศุกร์ครับอโอเวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
ครับเดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคม
ครับปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 25  65
ครับปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูนิก
ตอนตอนนี้นะครับเมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่เนี่ย
เวลา
86 นตอน
เช้าอืใช่แล้วเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่ตอนนี้
กี่โมงครับเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่ตอนนี้นะคะ
9  6 นค่ะตอนเช้าเหมือนกันโอเคตอนเช้า
เหมือนกันแต่เวลาห่างกัน 1 ช่ม 1 ชมงใช่
ค่ะแล้วเมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่เป็นยังไงคะวัน
นี้ฝนตกมยเตอนนี้ไม่ตกครับแต่ว่าเมื่อวาน
เนี่ยฝนตก
อื 2 วันที่แล้วฝนตกหนัก
ูใช่กี่ชั่วโมงอ่ะครูนิกคือตกหนักประมาณ
ว่าคือจริงๆครูนิกอ่ะไม่รู้แต่แฟนครูนิก
อ่ะมาบอกว่าตอนกลางคืนตกหนักแล้วเพราะว่า
อคือที่บ้านคุณนิกอ่ะคุณนิกก็เพิ่งรู้นะ
เหมือนกับเขามีไอ้เครื่องวัดความหนาของฝน
น่ะว่าถ้าเกิดสมมุติว่าน้ำมันท่วมเนี่ย
เหมือนกับมันจะวัดได้ว่ามันสูงกี่นิ้วอ่ะ
อ๋อแต่เา้าก็บอกคือเขาคก็ไปดูเครื่องวัดเ
บอกว่าเนี่ยเมื่อคืนน่ะฝนตกหนักเพราะว่า
ไอ้ตัววัดเนี่ยมันบอกว่าน้ำอ่ะมันสูง
ประมาณ 3 นิ้วอืเออคุณนิก็ก็เลยใช่คุณนิ
ก็แต่คุณนิก็งงนะว่าเอ้าก็ถ้าน้ำมันสูง 3
นิ้วแต่ทำไมพื้นมันไม่ท่วมมันก็เปียกแต่
มันไม่ได้เหมือนบ้านเราคือบ้านเรามันจะ
ชินว่าว่าถ้าฝนตกหนักปุ๊บเนี่ย
แฉกใช่น้ำนี่เต็มไปหมดเลยเต็มไปหมดแต่ที่
นี่คือมันไม่มีให้เห็นแบบนั้นไงเออเออมัน
มันอาจจะแบบไหลไปหมดแล้วก็ได้นะคะเพราะ
ว่าแบบเวลาที่ฝนตกอ่ะเราก็ไม่อยากทำอะไร
ใช่มั้ยหลายๆคนเนี่ยก็จะอยู่บ้านครับใช่
อืใช่มอยู่บ้านดูทีวีอเขียนหน่อยแล้วกัน
นะคะเดี๋ยวมันจะขาวไปหน่อยใช่ดูทีวีดู
ทีวีใช่มั้ยคะแบบถ้าคืออันนี้เนี่ยตอน
เนี้ยไม่รู้เพราะว่าตอนเทุกคนจะดูทีวี
เป็นแบบพวกสตีมมิ่ง
ใช่โทรศัพท์อืใช่ค่ะแต่ถ้าเมื่อก่อนน่ะ
เวลาเราดูทีวีเนี่ยมันไม่ได้เป็นสมิใช่
มั้ยคะเราก็จะดูรายการสมมติจะดูรายการซัก
อ่ะอาจจะไม่ใช่ 3 นาทีเนาะอาจจะ 5 นาที
ครับรายการเนี่ย 5 นาทีแล้วมันก็จะเบรคอื
เบรคประมาณ 1 นาทีใช่มันก็จะมีโฆษนา
ใช่ค่ะเบรคดูโฆษณาซึ่งถ้าเมื่อก่อนเนี่ย
พอเบรคโฆษณาเราก็จะเปลี่ยนช่องใช่มยเราจะ
ไม่ดูโฆษณาเพราะรู้สึกแบบเ่าเบื่อนะคะ
แล้วเราก็ใช่แต่ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยโฆษณาหลายๆ
โฆษณาเนี่ยเขาก็จะเหมือนกับโอหมีมีไอเดีย
แบบเยอะมากๆอ่าใช่เหมือนกับต้องเค้าเรียก
ว่าอะไรต้องดึงต้องดึงลูกค้าต้องดึงคนให้
สนใจมากขึ้นครับอืใช่เพราะว่าเวลาคนดู
แล้วแล้วเราก็ดูโฆษณาเราก็อยากจะซื้อใชม
ซื้อของมันต้องทำยังไงนะคะซึ่งที่เราพูด
ถึงโฆษณาเนี่ยเพราะว่าวันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิง
จะมีเกมมาเล่นกับครูนิกครับเกมอะไรครับ
เกมโฆษณาเนี่ยแหละค่ะคือหญิงเนี่ยจะมีรูป
นะมีรูปอจะเป็นรูปโฆษณานะคะแต่ครูหญิงก็
จะปิดไว้เ่ะตรงนี้ปิดอืแล้วครูนิกเนี่ยดู
รูปแล้วครูนิกต้องทาย
ว่าโฆษณาอะไรโครูนิกจะตอบเป็นยี่ห้อโฆษณา
ก็ได้อ่ะอย่างเช่นโฆษณารถโตโยต้าอย่าง
เงี้ยโฆษณายี่ merz อยี่ห้อได้ครับหรือ
ครูนิกจะตอบแค่ออโฆษณารถเออตอบเป็นของก็
ได้นะคะไม่เป็นไรอะไรก็ได้อ่ะลองดูเดี๋ยว
ลองดูนะคะเช้าเลยโฆษณาโฆษณาพวกนี้เนี่ย
เป็นโฆษณาเก่าแล้วหรือโฆษณาใหม่
อืุหญิงก็ไม่แน่ใจนะว่ามันจะเก่าหรือว่า
แต่ถ้าเก่าเนี่ยน่าจะไม่เกิน 5 ปี 6 ปี
ครูนิออ่าแต่ว่ามันจะเป็นเหมือนโฆษณาแบบ
เป็นป้ายเป็นแอดอ่ะค่ะอโโฆษณาก็คือแอด
เนาะเป็นป้ายนะไม่ใช่ที่ทีวีนะคะออโอเค
ได้ๆๆๆๆใช่อ่ะเรามาดูอันแรกเลยไม่ยากนะคะ
ไม่
ยากอือันนี้ก็เป็นแผ่นป้ายโฆษนาใช่มอัน
นี้ก็จะเป็นสีแดงๆนะคะอันคือครูหญิงปิด
เอาไว้นะคะสีดำเนี่ยโอเคอ่ะครูนิกเนี่ยดู
แล้วคิดว่าอันนี้เนี่ยโฆษณา
อะไรอันนี้เดานะมันจะต้องเกี่ยวอะไร
กับมะเขือ
เทศแล้วยาวๆเนี่ยนี่คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นซอส
มะเขือเทศใช่คอ่าโฆษณาซอสมะเขือเทศใช่
มั้ยคะใช่ๆเพราะดูจากรูปภาพนะเห็นไอ้ขั้ว
เค้าเรียกว่าตัวหัว
ของหัวของมะเขือเทศอ่ะมีใช่มใช่แล้วแต่
มันถ้ายาวๆอ่ะเก็คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นตอนแรก
ตอนแรกคิดว่าเป็นน้ำผลไม้แต่ว่าถ้าใน
ประเทศ
ไทยคนก็จะไม่ค่อยกินน้ำผลไม้มะเขือเทศ
เท่า
ไหร่อันนี้อาจจะไม่ได้มาจากประเทศไทยก็
ได้นะกูอืไม่แต่กำลังคิดว่าถ้าเกิดว่า
เป็นน้ำผลไม้มันต้องเป็นกล่องสี่เหลี่ยม
ไงแต่อันเนี้ยมันเป็นอก็เลยคิดว่าเป็นซอส
มะเขือเทศครับอ่ะครูนี้คิดว่าเป็นซอส
มะเขือเทศนะคะเรามาดูว่าจะใช่โฆษณาซอส
มะเขือเทศมั้ยิงก็ลบเอานะคะครู
นิกใช่ค่ะเนาะซอสมะเขือเทศยี่ห้อไฮมยอื
อืเพราะว่าเชอบมยยี่ห้อ
นี้คือูหญิงไม่ไม่รู้ว่าคือกินซอสมะเขือ
เท่แต่ไม่ไม่ไม่ได้คิดว่ายี่ห้ออะไรอ่ะ
เหมือนยี่ห้ออะไรก็กินได้อ่ะค่ะเออครูนิก
ครูนิกชอบไมยยี่ห้อนี้จริงๆครูนิกกินได้
ครูนิกแต่ครูนิกจะครูนิกอ่ะไม่ค่อยชอบกิน
ซ้อนมะเขือเทศอยู่แล้วคือกินได้เท่าเวลา
สั่งแบบเฟรนช์ฟรายแบบเนี้ยครับก็ถ้ามีมา
ให้ก็กินเพราะว่าคุณนิก็ถ้ากินเฟรนช์ไฟ
มันจะต้องมีอะไรจิ้มออๆๆถ้าที่ร้านมีแค่
ซอสมะเขือเทศก็อ่ะก็ได้กินคุณนิกอ่ะจะชอบ
กินมายองเนสอ๋อใช่เฟรนช์ฟรายจิ้มมายองเนส
มากกว่าคือมายเนสเนี่ยคุณนิกอ่ะกินกับ
อะไรก็ได้กินกับอะไรก็ได้เคยกินกับข้าว
มันไก่
ด้วยดูไม่ไปด้วยกันเลยนะมันไม่ไปด้วยกัน
แต่ว่าคือจริงๆมันก็อร่อยนะเพราะูนี้กับ
คูนิกใช้คำว่าคูนิกบ้ามายองเนสก็ได้เพราะ
ว่ามันคูนิินกับอะไรมันก็อร่อยอ่ะอืมใช่
แต่ก็มายองเนสเมื่อก่อนก็กินของยี่ห้อไฮ
เหมือนกันก็โอเคไม่แย่ครับออืแต่เหมือน
กับยี่ห้อนี้มันก็เป็นยี่ห้อที่ถ้าเป็นคน
ไทยคนไทยก็คิดว่าเป็นยี่ห้อที่ดีเพราะมัน
มาจากต่างประเทศแล้วก็ตามพิซซ่าก็ใช้
ยี่ห้อนี้อใช่ค่ะเป็นยี่ห้อดังอยู่นะใน
ไทยนะคะอ่ะอืคุนี้เก่งมากเรามาดูต่อไปค่ะ
ครับอื
อันนี้เป็นในรูปก็จะเป็นกีวี่นะคะขอขยับ
นิดนึงอ่าครูนิกเนี่ยเห็นแล้วใช่มกีวี่
แล้วเขาก็จะเหมือนเอาเม็ดนะคะเอาเม็ด
เนี่ยมันออกมาอครูนิคิดว่าป้ายโฆษณาอัน
นี้เนี่ยเา้าโฆษณา
อะไรกีวี่แต่มันไม่มีเม็ดออเหมือนเอาเม็ด
เล็กๆอ่ะเอาออกเอาออกเอาออกเขาจะสื่อถึง
อะไรเจะสื่อถึงอะไร
เอ่อบอกได้ว่าเป็นของ
ที่ใช้กับร่างกายของเราอ่ะไบ้ให้ใช้กับ
ร่างกายคือกำลังคุณนี้กำลังคิดว่าจะเป็น
เกี่ยวกับครีมทาหน้าหรือเปล่าที่เหมือน
กับพอใช้แล้วมันก็จะ
เนียนแต่อีกอย่างนึงมาคิดก็เอ๊ะหรือว่า
เป็นโคตโฆษณาแบบแหนบแบบแหนบเอาเม็ด
ออกอ๋อเหมือนเวลาที่เอาไว้ดึงใช่มั้ยดึง
ขนมันจะเป็นแหนบแล้วก็ดึงแหนบมันแบบบีบๆ
เล็กๆแล้วมันก็ดึงพวกขนหรือไปดึงอะไร
ออกไอเดียได้ไอเดียได้อ่าคล้ายๆกันแต่แค่
กำลังคิดว่าแล้วทำไมต้องเป็นกีวี่อือคือ
อันนี้คุฝินก็ไม่รู้ว่าทำไมเคใช้กีวี่นะ
คะแต่ไอ้โฆษณาของอันเนี้ยมันเหมือนกับ
ว่าไม่ใช่ทุกคนใช้
อ่ะแต่คุหญิงรู้สึว่าบางคนอาจจะใช้อย่าง
ตัวครูหญิงเองเป็นคนไม่ได้ใช้นะคะก็รู้
สึกว่าูนิก็ไม่น่าจะใช้ออเหรอเออโอเคคือ
คุณนิกำลังคิดว่าหรือเป็นที่ทาจั๊กแร้
อแต่เบอกว่าใช้ส่วนหน้าขึ้นไปหน้าขึ้นไป
หน้าขึ้นไปหรอ
อือ
ครูนิกคิดว่ามันเหมือนเป็นการทำความสะอาด
อ่ะค่ะคือเหมือนกับว่าไอ้เม็ดเม็ดกีวี่
อ่ะเม็ดกีวี่ตรงเนี้ย
เออใช่มันสิ่งสกปรกหรือ
เปล่าโฆษณาโทนเนอร์ใช่่มั้ย
ออเดานะโทนเนอร์ก็คือแบบที่เช็ดหน้าใช่
มั้ยคะเออคืออันนี้ดาวจากการที่ว่าเพราะ
ว่าปกติเนี่ยอ่ะก็ถ้าเป็นโทเนอร์เนี่ยมัน
ก็จะเช็ดเอาพวกสิ่งสกปรกหลังจากล้างหน้า
เสร็จแล้วว่าถ้ามันมีอะไรอีกหรือเดี๋ยว
พูดผิดไม่ใช่โทนเนอร์สิพูดใหม่ไอ้ที่ล้าง
เครื่องสำอางอ๋อพวกไมเซล่าใช่มั้ยคะใช่
อะไรพวกนั้นน่ะอือ๋อเหมือนเป็นพวกเค้า
เรียกอะไรอ่ะน้ำไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะคนไทย
เรียกว่าที่เช็ดเช็ดเครื่อง
สำอางมันใสยก็เป็นน้ำน้ำหรือบางบางที่ก็
ก็จะเป็นน้ำมันหรือบางอันก็จะเป็นเหมือน
เป็นเป็นก้อนเหมือน
กับใช่เป็นบาลก็อ่าใช่เช็ดเครื่องสำอาง
ใช่มั้ยคะเรามาดูเฉลยนะว่าอันนี้จะใช่
โฆษณาเช็ดเครื่องสำอางหรือเปล่านะคะคุนิ
เห็น
มยอันนี้มันที่ขัดฟันิใช่ๆไหมขัดฟัน
อออันนี้ก็ไม่รู้หรอกมันเออคือุหญิงรู้
สึกว่าคุณจะมันเกี่ยวอะไรกับกีวี่คือผุ
หญิงก็เลยสว่าคือไม่รู้ว่ากีวี่เนี่ยเขา
ต้องการสื่ออะไรไหมมันน่าจะไม่เกี่ยวกัน
กับ
ฟันคุณนิกอ่ะเดาเอานะว่าเพราะคุณนิกกิน
กีวี่แล้วคุณนิกสังเกตว่ากีวี่เนี่ยมัน
เหมือนกับตัวเนื้อกีวี่อ่ะครับถ้าดูดีๆ
มันมันจะเป็นเส้นๆเหมือนอย่างอย่างเงี้ย
ที่เราเห็นว่ามันจะมีเหมือนเป็นเส้นๆใช่
มั้เดาได้ว่าน่าจะคิดเน่าจะคิดว่าเป็น
เหมือนกับฟันเราว่ามันมีอะไรติดอยู่ใช่
ค่ะก็เหมือนแบบสะอาดมากใช่มั้แม้กระทั่ง
เม็ดกีวี่ที่เล็กๆเนี่ยมันก็ออกได้นะคะ
อันนี้คือโฆษณาไหมขัดฟันอืโอเคต่อไปนะคะ
ุอ่ะอันนี้ก็จะมีเหมือนขวดข้างในก็เป็น
หมอนนะคะหมอนๆหมอนอ่ะครูนิกดูจากรูปแล้ว
แผ่นป้ายคิดว่าอันนี้เนี่ยเค้าโฆษณา
อะไร
อืมคือถ้าครูนิกดูจากรูปเลยนะครับครูนิก
อ่ะคิดว่าน่าจะเป็นโฆษณาอย่าานอนหลับอื
แต่ก็คือกินแล้วให้หลับใช่กินแล้วแบบนอน
หลับเหมือนเวลาเรานอนยากก็กินก็จะจะทำให้
เราง่วงแล้วก็หลับได้ง่าย
ค่ะคุณนิก็เลยคุณนี้คิดว่าโฆษา
[เพลง]
ตามอากาศอาจจะเปลี่ยนหรือเปล่าคุณก็จะฮัด
ใช่อย่าเงี้ยคะอากาศอาจจะเปลี่ยนด้วยแต่
ว่าเมื่อ 2 วันที่แล้วคุณนิคุณนิกตัดขน
จมูกกูนึกก็เลยว่าอาจจะเป็นเพราะอันนั้น
ด้วยเพราะมันไม่มีขนจมูกที่ว่ามันเหมือน
เค้าเรียกว่าเลยมัน
กรองฝุ่นก็เลยเข้าได้ง่ายๆฝุ่นมันก็เลย
เข้ามาง่ายเลยเพราะว่าตั้งแต่ตั้งแต่พอ
ตัดขนจมูกคือคุณนิกชอบตัดขนจมูกอยู่แล้ว
แต่ทุกครั้งที่ตัดเนี่ยมันก็จะเป็นอย่าง
เงี้ยแหละครับมันแบมันมีอะไรเข้าได้อืแต่
อืมยานอนหลับหรอมันจะง่ายไปมั้ยอืนั่นสิ
นั่น
สิ
ครูนิกดูแล้วคิดว่าอันนี้น่าจะโฆษณาอะไร
คะแต่ทำไมมันมีเป็น
หมอนแต่ชื่อมันก็บอกไงครับว่าญาณว่ามัน
นอนก็ทำก็ถูกต้องแล้วนะ
ออ่ะคุณนิก้าคิดว่าโฆษณายานอนหลับคิดว่า
เหมือนกับเป็นพวก
โฆษณาโฆษณาอาหารเสริม
อืเหมือนพวกแบบคิดงวิตามินใช่อ่ะเอาว่า
โฆษณายานอนหลับไปเลยแล้วกันอ่าโฆษณายานอน
หลับเนาะก็คือกินแล้วทำให้เรานอนหลับสบาย
อ่ะเรามาดูจากอันแรกนะคะอันนี้เป็น
ราคากุนิกรู้แล้วอะไรถ้าเป็นโฆษณาแบบ
เนี้ยนะดูจากชื่อน่าจะเป็นโฆษณาของ
อีเกียใช่ค่ะโฆษณาของอีเกียออแสดวขาย
หมอนใช่ๆๆก็น่าจะเป็นแบบสื่อว่าหมอนของ
อีเกียเนี่ยก็คือคล้ายๆยานอนหลับใช่มั้ย
พอเราลงไปนอนที่หมอนของอีเกียปุ๊บหัวถึง
หมอนหลับเลยหลับเลยใช่เพราะหมอนแบหมอนแบบ
ดีอืนอนสบายมากนะคะออืโคต่อไป
ค่ะอันนี้หรออันนี้มันจะเป็นแบบอะไรนะคะ
มะเขือม่วงใช่มั้ยมะเขือม่วงแล้วตรงนี้ก็
เป็นเหมือนม่วงอสอสีคุณนี้คิดว่าอันนี้
โฆษณาอะไร
อืมคือคุณนิกเดานะว่ามันน่าจะเกี่ยวอะไร
กับสีธรรมชาติหรือเปล่า
[เพลง]
อืมันจะโฆษณา
อะไรถูกนะมาถูกทางมาถูก
ทางมาถูกทางแล้วค่ะเกี่ยวกับสีเกี่ยวกับ
ธรรมชาตินี่แหละแต่เป็นแต่สีมันก็มีหลายๆ
อย่างใช่มั้ว่ามันจะ
อะไรโฆษณาดินสอสีหรออ่าดินสอสีก็คืออัน
นี้แหละเนาะจริงๆนะใช่อันนี้ก็คือดินสอสี
ใช่มั้ยเวลาที่เราแบบว่ารูปแล้วเราก็เอา
สีใส่ลงไปมีหลายๆสีระบายอือ่ะครูนิกตอบ
แล้วนะคะว่าโฆษณาดินสอสีครับ
ดีถูก
ค่ะนาเป็นยี่ห้อเบอรคาสเทลนะคะเป็นดินสอ
สีเพราะครูนิก็พูดถูกว่าเขาบอกว่าสี
เหมือนสีมันจริงๆอ่ะอ่าสีตรงใช่ตรงกับ
ธรรมชาติหรือมันเอาไปเทียบกันได้ว่าอ๋อสี
นี้ไงเหมือนกับของอันนี้อืเหมือนสีม่วง
นี้ก็เหมือนกับมะเขือม่วงใช่มั้ยสีเหมือน
กันเลยสีตรงกันเลยแต่เมื่อก่อนสมัยเด็กๆ
เนี่ยถ้าเกิดว่าใครใช้ดินสอสียี่ห้อเย
ครับถือว่าเป็นคนมีพังรวยมากเพราะปกติเรา
ใช้ดินสอสีที่เป็นกล่องแบบนี้นะคะแล้วก็
มีดินสอสีเนี่ยประมาณ 12 แท่งสั้นๆนะน่า
จะประมาณเท่าไหร่ 20  30 ไม่แพงประมาณ 40
อ่ะมากที่สุดแต่ FA  CL ถูกสุดเ 100 บาท
เมื่อก่อนใช่ใช่อือือนะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูนิก
อุ้ยครูหญิงต้องขยับอันนี้ให้ครูนิกเห็น
เห็นแมวด้วยนะคะแมวครับเห็นเห็นเต่าอ๋อ
แมวนึกว่าเต่าเพราะเห็นแค่แมวน
เห็นมยอ่ะเห็นทั้งตัวมั้ยอ่ะเห็นทั้งตัว
หรือยังคะเห็นครับเห็นครับโอเคโอเคอันนี้
แมวใช่มยแล้วก็แมววิ่งไล่
กวางอยู่บนแบบภูเขาครูนิคิดว่าอันนี้น่า
จะโฆษณา
อะไร
อื้อหือโฆษณาอะไรล่ะอืที่แบบทำไมแมวมัน
ถึงวิ่งไล่กวางได้
อืทำไมแมวมันถึงดู
แบบแข็งแรงขนาดนี้ว่าอาหารแมวหรออืว่าถ้า
เป็นอาหารแมวที่เหมือนคุณภาพดีถ้ากินแล้ว
แมวจะแข็งแรงเหมือนกวางอืค่ะตื่นตัวแบบ
แอคทีเหมือนกวานหรือเปล่าอ่ะคุณนี้บอกว่า
โคณาอาหารแมวใช่มั้ยคะเออ
ครับเห็นมั้ยอ่ะใช่ใช่
ค่ะแต่กูหญิงคิดว่ามันน่าจะกินแล้วเป็น
เสือมากกว่าเอออ่าเพราะว่าอ๋อเป็นเสือ
แล้วก็ไล่กวางกวางก็เลยใช่เออเบกินแล้ว
แข็งแรงแต่ว่าเหมือนเสื่อนะคะนี้เป็น
โฆษณาอาหารแมวน่าจะได้อีกอันนึงเนาะอัน
นี้ละกันนะคะครูนิดูแล้วเนาะมันจะมี
เหมือนแก้วน้ำนะคะ
อ่าแก้วน้ำทำไมเออทำไมน้ำมันแปลกๆใช่แล้ว
ทำไมน้ำตรงนี้แบบมันหายแบบหายไปเลยมันน่า
จะสื่อถึงอะไรโฆษณาอะไรคุณนิกพอจะเดาได้
เพราะดูจากที่มันเป็นแถบคิดว่าน่าจะโฆษณา
เหมือนกับกระดาษทิชชู่หรือเปล่าอืเป็น
กระดาษทิชชู่ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ทิชชู่นะทิชชู่
เหมือนกับพอเช็ดแล้วก็หายเลยอืนะครูดีอก
ว่าอันนี้น่าจะโฆษณากระดาษทิชชู่นะคะอ่ะ
มาดูนี่เป็นภาษาอังกฤษนะคะ
อืแล้วก็
อ๋อก็ได้ก็จริงๆเปียทชเปียกใช่แต่ยี่ห้อ
นี้เนี่ยเขาจะเหมือนกับเป็นยี่ห้อเป็น
ทิชชู่เปียกที่มันมีน้ำยาเหมือนกับทำความ
สะอาดแล้วอืเหมือนมีพวกยาที่แบบเอาไว้
เหมือนเราถูพื้นเช็ดโต๊ะเช็ดคราบสกปรกได้
ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ๆอก็เหมือนคุณคิดว่าถ้าคนไทย
เวลาพูดว่าทิชชู่เปียกมันจะเป็นเหมือน
ทิชชู่เปียกเปียกที่เราเอาไปเช็ดตัวได้
เหมือนกับมันจะไม่มันจะไม่มีสารเคมีเยอะ
เหมือนกับว่าเอาไปเช็ดก้นเด็กหรือเอาไป
เช็ดหน้าเช็ดแขนแบบเนี้ยครับแต่ถ้าอันนี้
เช็ดแขนอาจจะแห้งนิดนึงอาจจะไม่ได้นะน่า
จะขสักคันใช่ๆอืจริงๆคนไทยเเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
ทิชชู่ทำความสะอาดหรอ
เออเเพราะว่าคนมันูหญิงก็ไม่แน่ใจนะแต่
ว่ามันก็คือเป็นคือบางคนคิดว่าก็อาจจะ
เรียกว่าทิชชู่เปียกแต่เหมือนกับก็ดูว่า
ยี่ห้ออะไรถ้ามันไม่ได้เป็นยี่ห้อที่
เหมือนกับว่าเราถ้ามันไม่ใช่เหมือนเป็น de
ตอหรือเป็นยี่ห้อเด็กๆไอ้ตัวอะไรอ่ะ
พีเจี้ยนอะไรพวกเนี้ยก็คงจะไม่เอาไปใช้
เช็ดตัวใช่อืแล้วก็จะเป็นแบบเห็นว่ากล่อง
มันเป็นรูปกระจกก็คงไม่เอาไปเช็ดตัวใช่ๆ
มันก็เป็นแบบก็ต้องดูว่ามันคือทิชชู่
สำหรับเช็ดอะไรเนาะก็เก็บอกว่าเหมันกแบบ
เช็ดแล้วแบบสะอาดมากแค่ 1 ครั้งนะคะก็วัน
นี้ก็เลยมาเล่นเกมถ่ายโฆษณากับครูนิกเนาะ
ก็สนุกๆนะคะได้ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ย
ครูหญิงกับครูนิกก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยว
เรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้าวดีโอต่อไปครับ
ค่ะสวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับผู้หญิง